l'état de santé des individus condamnés
et emprisonnés en russie ne devrait pas
susciter l'intérêt des représentants des
autres pays a estimé le porte-parole du
président russe dmitri peskov a
également souligné que le kremlin
n'avait aucune réaction aux récentes
déclarations de représentants
occidentaux hausse
à ce sujet il a également rappelé que
les appels à manifester en soutien dans
l'excès navalni sont lancés depuis
l'étranger je vous propose d'écouter
pâte en outre nous n'avons aucune
réaction à ce type de déclarations
faites par les représentants d'autres
états david guillocheau de l'état de
santé des individus condamnés et
emprisonnés en russie ne peut et ne doit
pas faire l'objet de leurs intérêts dans
le cas où des manifestations non
autorisées seraient initiés
elle serait automatiquement qualifié
d'illégitime et des forces de police et
la justice rendront vis-à-vis d'elle les
mesures prévues par la loi de la
fédération de russie
il est très important de rappeler qu'une
fois encore ses appels à caractère
provocateur ne sont même pas lancé dans
le sol russe ils sont lancés par des
individus séjournant à l'étranger il
serait probablement sens et de toujours
garder cela en mémoire l'état de santé
d'alexia navalni a été jugé satisfaisant
par le service pénitentiaire russe après
examen par un médecin
le posant russes purge actuellement une
peine de deux ans et demi de prison la
justice russe a évoqué en février
dernier le sursis dans une condamnation
remontant en 2014
il s'agit d'une affaire de détournement
de fonds dans la filiale russe du groupe
français yves rocher